after days of demonstrations across Iraq
the number of dead continues to rise in
the aftermath of the killings iran's
interior ministry pushed back on
eyewitness accounts that security forces
fired live ammunition of protesters -
everyone knows there were no armed
baffles clashes or confrontations
between the security forces and the
protesters but there were wicked and
heinous hands that targeted the victims
on both sides when we went and checked
the bodies of the martyrs the injuries
were in the head or the heart it is
clear that the shooting did not take
place from a close distance or from the
area where the security forces were
present a serious investigation is
ongoing to find out who is behind such a
wicked and heinous operation there have
been scores of casualties as
demonstrators vent their anger at a
government that's been in power for just
over a year the protesters are mainly
young men youth unemployment has now
reached 25 percent according to the
World Bank we the youth are protesting
peacefully what do they want from the
youth why are they killing us the
protesters say they've had enough of a
system that they say is corrupt and
serving the interests of a few they say
they don't support any political parties
but that hasn't stopped the political
opposition from backing the protesters
and calling for new elections I think
this is a case of political
point-scoring this is a systemic issues
so when you have parties refusing to
take part in parliamentary debates
making sure that there isn't a quorum so
that it can't go ahead this is all so
that they can pile on pressure on Park
Prime Minister I did have been Mehdi on
Sunday the Iraqi government pledged 17
reforms covering land redistribution
increased welfare payments to those in
need
and the construction of 100,000 new
housing units the government launched a
program of home demolitions in September
targeting the makeshift shelters of the
poor the head of the UN mission to Iraq
is called for the violence to stop in a
tweet one of the few international
voices to speak up as Iraq still
struggles to deal with the aftermath of
the invasion by the US and its coalition
of the Willing in 2003 she had returned
see al Jazeera
meanwhile Iraqis who are worried about
the safety of their family at home have
been staging a protest in front of the
White House members of this solidarity
rally said they can't get hold of their
family because of the shutdown of the
internet and they say the government
crackdown is an attack on democracy we
are here demonstrating and supported the
people of Iraq and this is a letter
addressed to the White House asking them
to help the Iraqi people and stand
against Iranian interference and we call
on the protests in Iraq to continue
we're here to support the people of Iraq
who getting killed in the peaceful
demonstrations for simply asking for
their rights they cut off their internet
they cut off their electricity so they
don't relay the message to the world and
we're here to show our support and to
tell them we stand with you and to say
Iran out out Iraq will remain free